Taylor Swift just dropped the title
track of her upcoming seventh studio
album lover and now everyone totally
thinks she's engaged to her longtime
love Joe Allen when it comes to love I
think the reason why we turned to music
is because we can somehow apply that
song to what we're going through in our
life this song first sparked engagement
rumors last week after Taylor dropped
some of the lyrics in her September
vogue cover story
[Music]
you better believe that those lyrics got
people talking fast because it's a
pretty solid nod to the something old
something new something borrowed and
something blue wedding tradition I write
songs about love constantly yeah so I
love the idea of it and I love writing
about it I think that it would be
wonderful to to end up with the right
person naturally when Taylor nation
heard the full track they did what they
do best investigative journalism now her
fans are more convinced than ever that
lover is a literal love letter to Joe
check out Exhibit A
the actor and tailor met in 2016 and if
math isn't your strongest subject let me
help you out
that's three yes three years people
three summers three years Exhibit B in
the lyric video a British flag appears
on the makeshift movie screen Joe is
from London so this seems to be a
not-so-subtle reference to his home
country
then there's Exhibit C the Christmas
[Music]
Tayler included a fake Christmas tree as
an easter egg in her me music video
telling fans on Instagram that it was a
clue for something one eagle-eyed fan
pointed out that there are two posts on
Joe's Instagram one from late December
and another from January where the
caption is simply evergreen tree emojis
seems dramatic but Queen Taylor is super
detail-oriented so I would not put it
past her
in fact she first started teasing the
track on Instagram back in 2018 but what
really has fans talking is the line
about our place which people seem to
think hints to the fact that they have
moved in together and finally the lyrics
set started it all
[Music]
so what does it all mean could Joe and
Taylor be engaged or done done married a
few other hints that suggests the two
are headed towards wedded bliss in
October Taylor was spotted wearing a cat
ring on that finger then of course
there's this proposal seen in the me
music video then there's this the track
clocks in at 3 minutes and 41 seconds if
you flip the numbers three for one
around you get one for three which means
I love you lover is the fourth song
Taylor has released off her upcoming
album she previously dropped me you need
to calm down and the archer Taylor
recently opened up to Vogue about the
new album saying it feels like a new
beginning adding quote this album is
really a love letter to love in all of
it's maddening passionate exciting and
chanting horrific tragic wonderful glory
her seventh studio album is set for
release on August 23rd but the day
before we'll get to see the music video
for lover and you can count on ET to
break down all the juicy details
until then I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now